this video is sponsored by fabulous in a
recent video on this channel i described
how simply squatting every single day
could unlock your lower body mobility in
a huge way so what's the upper body
equivalent of that well as it
happens that would be hanging so as an
exercise hanging is about as simple as
it can get you simply take a bar or a
branch any kind of anchor point and you
hang from it usually you use a pronated
overhand grip but there are lots of
variations and there's lots of slight
subtle differences in the way you hang
and the results that's going to get you
which we'll talk about in a moment first
why should you hang in the first place
well the first reason is that it can
offer decompression on the spine
essentially you're creating traction so
that the weight of your legs is
elongating the whole spine this is
fantastic for creating more space and at
the same time getting blood flowing into
all that tissue moreover though it can
add a little bit of extension to a part
of the body that's normally in flexion
challenge time can you hang from a
pull-up bar or tree branch and take your
t-shirt off without letting your feet
touch the ground
a lot of people lack mobility and
extension and thoracic and cervical
spines because they're always in that
curved over position this not only
increases risk of injury it also hampers
performance this makes it nearly
impossible to perform a straight
handstand for instance the same goes for
the overhead squat
the other issue here is shoulders once
again hanging can help to address this
by getting you back into that overhead
position not only will this restore a
position that's useful for a range of
tasks it also reduces the likelihood of
shoulder impingement and it can even
reverse existing issues in this regard
dr john kirsch claims that hanging can
actually physically move the acromion
and reshape the coracochromial ligament
to open up this space and allow for
greater and impeded movement this makes
a lot of sense to me i've always
wondered why it's so easy to cause
shoulder impingement just doing push-ups
wrong can cause this issue why can we so
easily get into a position that's going
to hurt us
seems like some bad evolutionary choices
to me
unless you acknowledge that we evolved
in an environment where climbing and
hanging radiation were more common and
sitting was far less so thus primitive
man had a physically different structure
around this area and was therefore far
less likely to cause injury this is why
i describe hanging as a fundamental
human movement it's something that is
conspicuously absent from our modern
routines and our bodies are worse off
for it we should be able to easily get
our hands above our heads it's why my
three-year-old daughter has zero problem
with shoulder dislocates just like she
can squat with these for minutes at a
time i want to be batman my
three-year-old daughter shouldn't be
kicking my ass at this stuff
hanging is the perfect tool to get us
back to where we should be at baseline
we're rediscovering basic skills we
should never have lost in the first
place it's also why movement guru edu
portal recommends a challenge where you
hang for seven minutes a day to build up
the missing mobility and strength i
think this is an excellent tip for
beginners but of course this is done
cumulatively throughout the day not in
one go which makes it another great way
to keep moving throughout the day and to
be shaped by your environment make sure
that you have some anchor points around
your home
of course lots of hanging will also
straighten out your posture as a result
of this a great blog petrofisher
movement explains how simply forcing
shoulders back and puffing your chest
out isn't a great solution to bad
posture this of course is what most of
us do when we're told to stand with our
shoulders back all you're really doing
she argues is tilting your rib cage to
improve the appearance of your posture
it's a band-aid that doesn't address the
root cause
moreover simply forcing yourself into a
better position is not sufficient you
can't possibly remember all the time to
bring your shoulders back and a little
mobility training a few times a week is
a very small stimulus compared to all
those countless hours spent sitting but
hanging from minutes a day is a big
stimulus
hanging on a regular basis is a
fantastic habit to form if you want to
improve back and shoulder health among
other benefits but how do you go about
forming a habit how do you overcome
issues like lack of motivation or simply
forgetting that's where a habit tracker
comes in a habit tracker like today's
sponsor fabulous the number one
self-care app to help you build better
habits and achieve your goals so
fabulous is a powerful tool that employs
insights from behavioral science to help
you form new habits and stick to them
you can select from a wide range of
curated recommended habits or create new
ones such as hanging you'll that way be
reminded to actually do the thing so
that you don't forget as someone who
likes to practice lots of smaller moves
throughout the day this is a great way
for me to keep track of all that
squatting hanging and stretching not
sure where to start fabulous comes with
over 100 recommended habits to help you
start improving right away or for an
even more tailored experience you can
join in with challenges set by the team
each week these include a host of
activities known to greatly improve your
life whether you're interested in
nutrition mindfulness fitness or even
tidiness tidiness being my personal
sticking point through circles you'll be
able to get support and ideas from
members with similar goals to you
fabulous is a genuinely great tool for
those that want to make real change in
their lives after all new habits and
routines are meaningless unless you
actually stick with them
start building your ideal daily routine
the first hundred people who click the
link below will receive 25 off their
fabulous subscription
another reason to hang is to build
shoulder strength and stability in an
inherently unstable position this can
again reduce the risk of injury and
build a lot more strength for a range of
other movements this is where the
distinction needs to be made between the
dead hang or passive hang and the active
hang in dead hangs or passive hangs you
allow the shoulder to raise up by the
ears and try to relax all the muscles as
much as possible this is best for
mobility and you should feel that
stretch on the pecs and the lats it's
also a great opportunity to practice
relaxation and breathing during physical
exertion
in an active hang however you depress
the shoulders and you support your
weight slightly you want to keep your
arms straight but contract the shoulders
and your core and make yourself rigid
this is best for stability and it can
help with everything from your bench
press to rock climbing edo and others
recommend training a combination of both
for optimal results
more profound still when it comes to
your performance is the amazing work
that hanging does for your grip hold
onto a branch or a bar and after a while
you'll start to feel the burn in your
forearms and your hands this translates
to a better grip in any lift which means
stronger lifts it also means a great
grip for climbing so hopefully that's
convinced you now how do you get started
well the key is to build up to this and
not to work through pain if you have a
painful shoulder impingement then
hanging off of it will only exacerbate
the issue instead get into a position
that you can hang comfortably with no
pain potentially this might mean
supporting your weight slightly on your
feet but then as you improve you can
reduce the amount of support you give
yourself more and more for those with no
issues of course the aim is to increase
your time so start with the aim of 30
seconds and build up from there
for those that want to take this further
there are lots of cool variations and
ways to increase the challenge obviously
you can add weight my favorite way to do
this is by keeping a medford between my
feet as this adds to the traction more
so than wearing a vest
hanging from one arm is also an option
if you have the necessary strength this
is obviously a bigger grip challenge and
greater for shoulder mobility
i also highly recommend getting outside
and doing this on a tree branch this
massively increases the challenge as
your hands will be at different heights
and you'll probably struggle to get your
thumb around the branch
this in turn forces you to grip as you
would when climbing anything outside of
the gym making it more akin to a
tactical pull-up
and sometimes the branch will even be
wet keep in mind that it's sometimes
hard to find the right type of tree with
a nice horizontal branch i've been to
woods where i can't find a single one so
keep your eyes open throughout your day
and make a note of them when you see
them
too small
i'm not an expert of trees but i believe
you call this one
pull up a tree
my favorite variations also benefit from
the space that a branch offers so for
example traversing the branch sideways
is awesome it's fun it feels practical
and it requires you to take all your
weight on one hand for brief spells a
great precursor to other things or why
not turn around on the spot you can also
lift the legs and hang on a v-sit in
order to engage the abs and hip flexors
a little more
another great variation though is to
swing this can be swinging from side to
side which creates a bigger dynamic
stretch on the lats or swinging forwards
and backwards which is a bigger grip
challenge and builds even more shoulder
and back mobility swinging is loads of
fun and it's great for building up to
movements like the parkour lashes hangs
are popular with tracers in general so
if you want to move like our friend liam
from parkour journeys then you need this
in your life
monkey bars are even better for all this
stuff
don't worry i left as soon as any
children arrived as a parent i know how
annoying it is when youths monopolize
the playground
youths like me
oh and did i mention that this is all
great for the core too spend some time
hanging and swinging and you'll feel it
in your abs the next day
big time
so what do you guys think will you be
hanging and swinging if you like this
kind of training that combines mobility
strength athleticism and more then you
might enjoy my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
that program aims to target every aspect
of performance in a way that's
accessible and adaptable to all and
naturally includes hanging the product
contains an 80 plus page ebook as well
as over two hours of video tutorial
walking you through every movement and
every progression i'll put a link to it
in the description down below either way
guys thank you so much for watching this
one please do like if you enjoyed the
video it really does help
and subscribe if you want to see more
like this the batman training video is
now very nearly finished
and of course
bye for now